[Musique]
bonsoir petit ami puis cachez derrière
en énorme buisson
j'attendis le ciel était à l'orage
soudain un tigre surgit qu'en
pensez-vous patron ce n'est pas mal oui
nounours mais il nous tarde de connaître
la fin de ton histoire n'est-ce pas les
enfants c'est pour ce soir pas trop ce
soir je finis d'écrire le livre des
mémoires d'un nounours au travail
[Musique]
oui vous êtes attendus avec une certaine
impatience cher nounours que ce jour tu
vois je me mets vite au travail
[Musique]
je ne vois pas mon cahier
c'est froid très froid oh oui c'est
glacé
j'ai besoin de mon cahier pour
travailler je ne vais tout de même pas
jouer à chaud et froid pour le retrouver
j'ai cependant l'impression que c'est ce
qui va se passer bon petit drôle vous
allez voir si je vais le retrouver mon
cahier
[Musique]
vers la fenêtre non ami et là
à présent tu brûles
en plus ça devient trop froid j'aime ça
moi
[Rires]
et après
je brûle
[Musique]
je ne comprends plus rien je brûle je
gèle ce n'est pourtant pas difficile
oh mais
alors amis vous pataugez non data
Pépita viens encore me dire bonjour
[Musique]
[Rires]
petit diable que vous êtes
heureusement que je n'écris pas moi
[Musique]
dors vite cornichon bonne nuit
patron ça y est je l'ai tu as bien
travaillé non mais on ne peut pas
travailler s'amuser
et vous vous êtes bien amusés oui et moi
je préfère m'amuser aussi je finirai
d'écrire les mémoires d'un nounours
pendant les grandes vacances ou alors
on s'en va oui en route bonne nuit les
enfants faites de beaux rêves
[Musique]